et
amanda lear à sortir un nouveau livre
qu'elle veut qu'elle veut et elle fait
des révélations étonnantes de dents
notamment une tune a fait beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup parlé elle a déclaré
on n'attend pas 40 ans pour dire
monsieur polanski m'a mis la main au cul
labéda
1 mondial n'a jamais vraiment eu la
langue dans sa poche moi je pense que
quand on est artiste surtout on est
obligé de fermer sa gueule dans son bref
quelle vie publiée ce jeudi l'actrice et
chanteuse sont des prix où nous avons
mis tous on ne se rend pas dans la
chambre d'hôtel d'un producteur et c'est
vous reçoit en pyjama on lui dit je vous
attends au bar on stars avant que la
situation ne s'envenime situation qui
fait référence à une histoire
personnelle dans ses débuts amanda lear
avait été elle-même conviés dans la
chambre du réalisateur américain darren
à nuque elle poursuit en intrigue non un
peu certaines victimes qui se serait
jeté dans la gueule du loup tout en
protestant les conséquences on n'attend
pas 40 ans pour dire monsieur polanski
m'a mis la main au cul il faut pas que
c'était n'importe quoi pour décrocher un
rôle alors amanda lear s'insurge contre
le mouvement mythe ou êtes-vous d'accord
avec elle
alors est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
l'aéroport
attend les eaux calmes calmez-vous
jocelyne on va en parler moi je vous le
dis il ya des femmes qui sont pas
connues kiki ou qui pensent un peu comme
elle mais même des connus inquiet mais
le débit ne voulait pas bizarrement même
des connu je me souviens aussi des
déclarations catherine deneuve juste
après d'ailleurs le mouvement lit tout
et après beaucoup de paroles qui s'était
enfin libérée bizarrement ce sont
toujours celles qui appartiennent à une
autre époque celle qui appartiennent à
un autre temps qui trouvait ce un petit
peu normal un peu consensuel aussi
normale petit mot qu c'est flatteur
bernois en fait les victimes elles
réagissent comme aide l'homme et le
robot mais non je suis pas d'accord mais
vous l'avez dit si choqué bordel on est
d'accord
je suis chaud
avec ses scandales et ce qu'elle dit
c'est honteux non cher quand je suis
d'accord nous on me demande non non moi
je trouve que et c'est amanda lear c'est
par mireille mathieu
toujours été la position très cocasses
et puis elle est la verse du mouvement
mis tout pour profiter des hommes et
elle ne le cache pas d'ailleurs on se
souvient c'est d'avis qu'il a découvert
qu'il a vendu mondialement mondialement
célèbre et c'est david bowie entre
autres qui va lui apprendre à maîtriser
son corps et qui va l'initier vraiment à
l'art pour moi je moi je dis bravo
amanda alors le coup dire des choses que
d'autres n'osent pas dégueulasse a les
traits de la jeune et je sais que vous
êtes alors il ya une partie ces propos
avec lesquelles jouaient pas d'accord
quand elle dit on ne va pas dans la
chambre d'un producteur de tel c'est
d'un producteur de cinéma là je suis pas
d'accord parce que c'est pas parce qu'on
va dans une chambre que ça autorise le
mec à faire n'importe quoi en premier
votre âge en revanche ce qu'elle dénonce
et pas mis tous et les dérives du
mouvement mis tout et je pense qu'il
faut faire quand même la différence
entre des faits extrêmement graves qu'il
faut combattre comme les agressions
sexuelles ou les viols et certains
propos qui aujourd'hui semble et à juste
titre complètement déplacé mais qui
était malheureusement toléré il y a 20
ans 30 ans 40 ans échéance que c'est ça
aussi qu'elle dénonce des remarques un
peu sexiste qu'il ya 30 ans on pouvait
prononcer on a parlé de tout à l'heure
avec jean-pascal des propos aujourd'hui
qui peuvent être perçus comme homophobe
qui était toléré qui était diffusée à la
télévision française sur tf1 à une heure
de grande écoute ça ne choquait personne
je pense qu'elle remet un peu les choses
dans leur contexte en revanche je suis
pas d'accord avec elle quand elle dit on
va pas dans la chambre d'hôtel d'un
producteur non c'est pas parce qu'on va
dans la chambre d'hôtel de quelqu'un ça
autorise le maire à faire tout et
n'importe quoi et agressé sexuellement
une femme moi c'est cette phrase là que
je trouve j'adore amanda lear mais cette
phrase à elle est allée or seuls puisque
on n'attend pas 40 ans pour dire à
monsieur polanski que monsieur polanski
m'a mis la main au cul ils ont attendu
mi tout mais malheureusement les femmes
on les écoutait pas les entendent et
nausées pas dans la violence qui s'est
pas seulement une main aux fesses en
rideau la valeur mais c'est comme si je
n'avais pas attendu car on met ses
mythes uribe s'est mis tout qui a libéré
la parole donc évidemment concerne
attendu 40 ans elles ont attendu qu'on
les entende sachs a cédé 7 ans je suis
pas d'accord pour ça que ce que dit
guillaume est très juste je crois qu'il
ya deux poids deux mesures des fois on
est obligé d'attendre parce qu'ils sont
des faits très graves il faut pouvoir
aller se plaindre c'est dur pour une
femme d'aller parler si un viol etc moi
je suis pas d'accord avec elle par
contre c'est vrai il a tout à fait
raison si vous avez un producteur qui
arrive avec le move à l'herbe on va
faire le casting on prend des contres
c'est pas pour me faire faire un film
c'est
avec cette partie de la phrase sur on
n'attend pas 40 ans quand on a été
violée effectivement il ya une période
dans laquelle on peut pas parler par
contre je suis d'accord avec elle quand
on est on va pas faire un casting oui
avec un producteur en pyjama on lui dit
je t'attends en bas il faut savoir
j'avais raconté ici une anecdote avec
harry winston il faut savoir qui a quand
même aussi beaucoup de femmes qui ont
profité d'un certain système j'en
connais personnellement qu'ils sont plus
ou moins connus qui ont raconté à tout
paris que c'était le meilleur coup de
paris et qui ensuite quand la ferme et
tout est sorti on écrit une tribune pour
dénoncer quel monstre c'était donc il ya
des gens qui ont aussi joué le jeu et ça
va participer à entretenir ce système
horrible et donc alors il au magazine
now there to s'inscrit effectivement
j'ai fait que quand on prend rendez vous
avec un producteur à minuit dans une
tour d'hôtel c'est pas pour parler
boulot
du coeur de bien se comporter aussi ça
n'avait pas l'autorisation
pour certaines pour certaines les
paroles de la grande attention et nos
jours certaines certaine et consentants
et se sont vantés d'avoir entre
guillemets séduit banshee et après quand
le mouvement dit oui tu arrives et ont
retourné leur veste et on dit il m'a
violée il a buzzé mois ce qui n'enlève
rien
il n'est pas prête il pas près de 2
c'était tout un écosystème en fait c'est
ça le c'est pas juste une personne c'est
tout un système s'entretient et
justement bertrand il ya aussi l'autre
l'autre affaire qui a fait grand bruit
dans lequel le prince rob andrew
stein
chose alors en quête de sexe et encore
vous dire c'est toujours aussi grâce aux
c'est grave ouais c'est terry parce que
là pour le coup ils ont vraiment en
quelque sorte acheter la victime pour
qu'elle se taise on sait que ça s'est
réglé à coups de millions de nombreux
millions c'est le prince charles la
petite anecdote car prêter de l'argent à
son frère le prince andrew tellement il
a fallu d'argent on parle de 10 millions
de livres c'est de cet ordre là
avec notamment des riches ou ses propos
totalement
inapproprié hors sol hors du temps vous
avez des femmes qui ont mis 20 30 40 ans
à pouvoir enfin exprimer quelque chose
avec lequel elles ont vécu on est en ce
moment au coeur d'un scandale qui est la
sphère ppda vous avez énormément de
femmes qui enfin on vous parlait après
dix quinze vingt ans à venir ce sont des
gens qui sont en train de crever de
mourir ok il ya peut-être 3 % des gens
qui veulent qu'ils veulent profiter qui
veulent profiter d'un lecteur de choses
mais là aujourd'hui je veux dire
heureusement heureusement que les
victimes peuvent parler enfin s'exprimer
vous avez la peur de quoi il a perdu
pouvoir fasse un ppda vous fait quoi
quand vous êtes à tf1 et que vous gagnez
et vous avez ou le petit salaire tous
les mois vous allez allez voir qui le
patron pour dénoncer le truc d'ailleurs
on a bien vu dans le reportage sahélo
vallerand s'était fait que le patron
connaissait parfaitement les problèmes
le patrick poivre d'arvor à l'intérieur
de tf1 donc ça je trouve ça totalement
scandaleux et je suis très étonné que ça
vienne d'elle les abus oui il y en a
mais c'est 2 3 % des gens aujourd'hui
vous avez des abus de femmes qui prône
armes et des femmes qui sait peut-être
que 3% des cas mais la majorité des
femmes ou des hommes puisqu'il ya aussi
des hommes sont des victimes avant tout
donc respect pour les victimes merci
nicolas a dit non moi je dis que c'est
des sujets qui sont très sensibles parce
qu'effectivement je suis d'accord je te
rejoins il ya des il ya des gens qui
profitent et qui qui vont et cetera puis
il ya aussi des mensonges on sait jamais
trop comment se positionner c'est très
très délicat que d'un côté tu as des
gens tu dis ok peut-être qu'ils vont se
suicider parce qu'il se retrouve au
milieu d'une affaire qui est extrêmement
grave parce que je rappelle que ces cds
pénal c'est des assises c'est pas se
passe pas rien c'est énorme et puis il
ya aussi des victimes qui effectivement
nommés doivent prendre le temps par les
ailes elles ont ce droit de parler à
n'importe quel moment quand l on nous
envie mais moi le meilleur conseil est
la meilleure réponse que je peux donner
c'est vraiment aller déposer plainte à
aller à la police parce qu'effectivement
les grands patrons ne réagiront pas on
l'a vu les seuls qui pourront agir ce
sont les autorités et les seuls qui
pourront aider et déceler c'est la
police et pas les médias c'est pas nous
nous on peut pas savoir andré on n'était
pas là on fait pas ce qui se passe par
contre la police doit enquêter donc
allez vous plaindre à la police le plus
vite possible et n'ayez pas peur ce qui
est essentiel dans ces affaires pénible
c'est que c'est un traumatisme réel pour
ces femmes alors même si ses quarante
ans après elles sont elles sont blessés
à vie donc c'est insupportable moi ce
que je dis c'est qu'il faut pas qu'ils
aient de prescription il faut vraiment
se battre là dessus est remonté à 2
passes ont fait là ses options mais bon
on peut remonter jusqu'à l'enfance
il a démarré la parole mais ça sert à
rien personne va être condamné parce
qu'à chaque fois y apprécier le charme
c'est pour ça que c'est pénible